the 2-day lull in bombing ended on
Wednesday as Russian and Syrian jets
were reported to have attacked several
rebel hill towns in the northwest
province of Edler activist video showed
charred vehicles damaged buildings and
casualties being treated a
representative from the white helmet
search-and-rescue group said civilians
were among the casualties in Idlib city
in the afternoon
it Lib city was targeted by Sukhoi 23
jets they hit the industrial area and al
Holl market most of those hurt have
serious injuries Al qaeda-linked groups
are the strongest forces in these areas
but the UN says some three million
civilians remain here - under the
ceasefire brokered by Turkey which
supports the rebels and Russia which
supports the Syrian government
airstrikes were to have ceased on Sunday
Moscow says it's been targeting rebels
who've been attacking civilian
government held areas in what was
supposed to be a de-escalation zone
brokered in 2018 also by Turkey and
Russia the UN says some 700,000 people
have been displaced in ad-lib over the
last eight months Turkey and Russia are
reported to have been negotiating the
establishment of a secure zone in the
region whether his displaced can find
safety during the winter in addition
Moscow has announced that safe corridors
have already been established - an hour
residence of it Lib to cross over into
government-held territory but it's
unclear yet as to how many have chosen
to do so sheer brute antsy Al Jazeera